starting this our office Ottoman
Colorado hi autumn welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up so I currently
do uber and I so I don't have anywhere
that I could put my money that I know of
save it for like social security or like
a 401 account I have about sixty eight
thousand dollars of debt it's more
student loan car payments and a debt
consolidation loan so I just I don't
know where to start like I've been
saving up some money so that I could pay
off my car payment I give them an extra
five hundred a month and my student loan
it it's in forbearance right now so I
need to take it out it's like a start
making payments but I don't know how to
save for my future if I just put it in
the bank okay I wouldn't save for your
future right now I would put it all on
the debts let's list your debts smallest
to largest pay minimum payments on
everything but the smallest debt and
every dollar you can squeeze out of your
budget any money that you have free
we're gonna throw at that smallest debt
so you have student loan and car and
what else
debt consolidation how much is the
student loan 23,000 23 how much do you
owe on your car 27 okay and what's your
debt consolidation loan 17 okay cool and
what's your household income well I
don't I don't know so I bring in about
thirty eight hundred a month tax-free
okay that'd be like forty eight thousand
dollars roughly before taxes before
taxes are taken out yes okay so why not
world are you driving a twenty seven
thousand dollar car I don't know it's an
off the awfully expensive car for no
more money than you make it
and so it's dragging you at that time I
was I was working a better job at the
time but I got laid off Oh
what were you doing I worked for Kaiser
Permanente I was a claim processor
playing processor and how much did you
make doing that um close to 60 a year
okay so the uber is a stopgap till you
land a more permanent gig yes it's not
like your long-term career goal no
absolutely okay and so how's the job
hunt coming
um well I'm in the process of moving
from one state to another so I haven't
really even looked for another job
because I don't know how long I'm gonna
be in Colorado oh okay so when are you
moving how do you not for another six
months why it's just more it's cheaper
to live somewhere else no why are you
waiting six months oh you don't have a
job you're waiting you're you got your
life on hold until you move why not just
go to those my lease is up oh you gotta
finish the lease out okay don't you talk
to landlord about what under what
circumstances you might be able to let
you out yes I paid three times the rent
I'm sorry I would pay three times the
rent to break the lease that's what the
landlord said or the lease says yes the
apartment okay is the apartment full by
chance
hmm I don't know don't you stop by the
manager's office and ask them I know my
lease says it's three times the rent I
can stay the whole six months but I'd
like to be let out is there anything I
can do to just be let out because they
might be able to rent the apartment for
more than you're paying if they're full
and they might just let you go if you do
that get it in writing of course okay if
not you're gonna stay six months and
then we're gonna work on your income
because your car does not fit your
current income you've got to get your
income up or this car needs to go but
you can hang on for six months it's just
you've got an awful lot tied up in
vehicles that go down in value and
you're putting miles on it running over
on it yes so I'm stopping Oh miles
tough my
not road miles so you know that that's
what we're looking at okay so we're
gonna list our debts smallest to largest
I would leave the student loans in
forbearance for now and I would just
attack the $17,000 consolidation loan
because you may or may not be keeping
this car I don't know but let's just
attack it as hard as you can go at it
and let's see how fast we could get it
paid off if you put $2,000 a month on it
that'd be a lot but you'd be done in
like eight months yeah if you put $1,000
you'll be done in 17 months that's not
enough I need to do more than that so
you need to set some goals doing that
and right now I don't want you investing
until you get your debts cleared off
because when you don't have any payments
but your rent and your your food and
that kind of stuff you will be able to
save and invest a whole lot more a whole
lot more efficiently